العديد مشاهدينا من اللاعبين عانوا من
الاكتئاب والازمات النفسيه يا عادل سواء
خلال ممارستهم لكره القدم او حتى بعد
اعتزالهم النجم الايطاليا روبرتو بارجو
احد ابرز اللاعبين الذين عانوا من
الاكتئاب خلال ممارسته لكره القدم بسبب
اضاعته ركله الجزاء الشهيره ضد البرازيل
في نهائي مونديال عام
1994 راويه طبعا اصيب باضطرابات يوميه قبل
النوم ولم تنتهي معاناته الا مع الاعتزال
والابتعاد النهائي عن كره القدم هناك ايضا
لاعبين اخرين
نجم منتخب انجلترا في الثمانينيات
وتسعينيات القرن الماضي عانى هو الاخر من
الاكتئاب وادمان الكحول بعد اعتزال للكره
بسبب ابتعاد عن الاضواء ورغبه في الانتحار
بعد انفصال عن زوجه ايضا بسبب سوء معاملته
لهذه الزوجه وكان الانتحار للاسف حلا لدى
بعض نجوم الرياضه ابرزهم الحارس الالماني
الذي انا حياته في عام 2009 بعد معا لمده
سبع سنوات مع الاكتئاب بسبب تسببه بخساره
فريقه برشلونه والهجوم الكبير عليه من قبل
الجمهور ايضا الحال بالنسبه لنجم المنتخب
الويلزي
الذي قرر انهاء حياه في العام 2011 بعد ان
وصل لمراحل المتقدمه من الاكتئاب لم تنفع
معها اي اساليب علاجيه ايضا تغيرت حياه
النجم البرازيلي ادريانو لاعب انتر ميلان
ومنتخب البرازيل السابق عقب وفاه والده
المفاجئه ليضمن المخدرات ويصبح مجردا في
شوارع البرازيل بعد سنوات للاسف تخيلوا من
التالق
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات